the 42nd chapter of the book of ice
clearly foretells the coming of an
Arabian prophet specifically Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
I say it describes itself as a prophecy
about the future God states that the
former things have taken place and new
things I declare God starts the chapter
by drawing our attention to a very
special person that he was send he
describes this person as my servant whom
I uphold my chosen one in whom I delight
at least three of the names of the
Prophet Muhammad I mentioned servant
chosen one and in whom I delight I say
it is originally written in Hebrew
Arabic and Hebrew sure a lot of common
words because they are both Semitic
languages I say it uses the Hebrew word
Abed for servant the Arabic word for
servant is Abaddon Prophet Muhammad is
known as God's servant in Arabic
Abdullah chosen one is Mustafa in Arabic
this is another of the names of the
Prophet Muhammad the one in whom God
delights in shows that this person is
beloved to God Habib Allah in Arabic
which means beloved of God also happens
to be one of the Prophet Mohammad's
names
and I say God also reveals the location
of this special person he states let the
wilderness and it's towns raise their
voices let the settlements where kadar
lives rejoice out of all the nations on
earth that God inspired Isaiah to
mention he chose to highlight Kedar
location so we should pay special
attention throughout the Bible ke Dodd
and his sons are linked to Arabia for
example The Book of Ezekiel tells us
that Arabia and all the princes of Kedar
were your favorite dealers and lambs
Rams and goats in these they did
business with you
and I say a God goes on to narrow the
location down further to a specific city
within Arabia
he states that the people of Silla
should sing for joy let them shout from
the mountaintops the place Allah
pinpoints the exact location in Arabia
the place being spoken of is the city of
Medina in Saudi Arabia because Salah is
the name of a famous mountain in Medina
Medina was the city of the Prophet
Mohammed
an important point worth mentioning is
that historically we know there was a
presence of various Jewish tribes in
Medina before the advent of the Prophet
Muhammad both Jewish historians and
Islamic history records this fact the
question then arises why were the
numerous Jewish tribes within Medina the
answer is that the Leonard Jews were
aware of this prophecy in Isaiah and
were anxiously awaiting the coming of a
new prophet Islamic history records the
fact that whenever a dispute arose
between the Jews and the Arabs in Medina
the Jews used to taunt their pagan Arab
neighbors by saying when our prophet
arrives we shall obliterate you the
Quran also affirms this God says is it
not a sign to them that the learned men
of the children of Israel knew it as
true
in i say 'god informs us that the
special person will bring something new
mankind is told that we will sing to the
Lord a new song his praise from the ends
of the earth the statement a new song
means a new law a new way of worship
this is exactly what Islam represents
the emphasis on the new song here is
singing the praise of God all over the
earth the Quran opens with the statement
praise be to God Lord of the Worlds and
is recited by Muslims all over the world
during prayers every day the new song
cannot refer to Jesus because he did not
bring about anything new rather he
confirmed the law of Moses that was
already there in the Gospel of Matthew
Jesus said think not I am come to
destroy the law or the prophets I am not
come to destroy but fulfil Jesus obeyed
and followed the law of Moses throughout
his life Jesus didn't sing a new song he
sang the same song of Moses the Torah
moreover the disciples of Jesus also
follow the law of Moses even after Jesus
departed in the book of Acts we are told
that the disciples look to the Torah for
guidance
for the law of Moses has been preached
in every city from the earliest times
in i say 'god emphasizes the universal
mission of the coming person by
mentioning that he will be made a
covenant all the people and a light for
the Gentiles Gentiles means non-jews the
Quran confirms the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him was sent to the whole
of mankind Jews and Gentiles alike in
the Quran God tells us we have sent you
a prophet as a bearer of glad tidings
and a Warner for the whole of mankind
but most people have no knowledge the
verse in Isaiah can not apply to Jesus
because in the Gospel of Matthew Jesus
said I was sent only to the lost sheep
of Israel and I say a God further states
that he will lead the blind byways they
have not known along unfamiliar paths I
will guide them the pagan Arabs at the
time of the Prophet Mohammed fit this
description perfectly because they had
not been sent a messenger prior to
Muhammad the Quran bears witness to this
God states that Muhammad was sent to
Warner people to whom no Warner has come
before the verson I say cannot apply to
Jesus because his people the Israelites
had already received a multitude of
prophets from God in Isaiah God
emphasizes that this special person will
be sent to those who trust in idols who
say to images you are our gods the whole
of Arabia at the start of Muhammad's
prophethood consisted of idol
worshippers again this cannot be a
reference to Jesus because his people
the Israelites were monotheists and not
Island worshipers
moreover Jesus explicitly told his
disciples to stay away from the
idol-worshipping Gentiles the exact
opposite of what God prophesized in
Isaiah the Gospel of Matthew tells us
that these twelve Jesus sent out with
the following instructions do not go
among the Gentiles
in Isaiah God states that this special
person will be a warrior and will go
forth as a mighty man he shall stir up
jealousy like a man of war he shall cry
yay roar he shall prevail against his
enemies throughout history God has dealt
sternly with those who are sent guidance
and persist in disbelief Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him had to engage
in many battles with the
idol-worshipping enemies of God and
ultimately prevailed against them by
comparison Jesus did not triumph over
his enemies according to Christians he
was crucified by them moreover Jesus
wasn't interested in fighting he was not
a man of war he was a pacifist according
to the Bible he said such things as for
all who draw the sword will die by the
sword and my kingdom is not of this
world if my kingdom were of this world
then would my servants fight
in Isaiah God gives us a list of
momentous achievements for this special
person chief of these is that the idol
worshipers will be turned back in utter
shame not only did the Prophet Muhammad
conquer Mecca the pagan capital of
Arabia but by the end of his life in
just 23 short years of prophethood
Arabia had shunned idol worship and now
worshipped the one true God of Abraham
this cannot apply to Jesus as it was
Christians themselves who were
humiliated and greatly ashamed for
hundreds of years after Jesus they were
persecuted at the hands of the Roman
Empire who are Idol worshipers they
executed some of the Apostles of Jesus
such as Peter and Paul Christians were
tortured and even fed to the Lions
finally I say a closes with an
admonishment from God here you deaf look
you blind and see you have seen many
things but you pay no attention your
ears are open but you do not listen
which of you will listen to this or pay
close attention in time to come it seems
clear that a deaf and blind God is
talking about in this verse are those
who reject Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him who among you will heed God by
acknowledging him who will listen and
pay close attention in time to come
levena at the neo-noir sona-nyl
me Olivia de Donohue Matt Dubin I will
feed them what you will
delia more wounded mouths
you